welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and with the
recent Buzz surrounding Disney Plus's
upcoming Wonder Man series including
rumors that comedy Legend Bob Odenkirk
is being eyed for a role I've been
thinking about what exactly we can
expect in a series surrounding the mcu's
stunt acting Avenger today I'm breaking
down what we know about the series thus
far and the characters we can expect to
join wonderman's Hollywood Entourage and
I've got doubles no triples of theories
let's start with a quick rundown of the
star of the show Wonder Man himself will
be played by matrix Watchmen and Aquaman
star Yaya Abdul Mateen in the comics
Wonder Man AKA Simon Williams was a
young white-collar criminal who got
bailed out of jail by Baron zemo's
masters of evil in exchange he was
convinced to become zemo's test subject
for the ionic Ray a super power
development process through these
experiments Wonder Man would develop
super strength invulnerability and
eventually immortality as well as a
bunch of energy-based powers by the end
of his first issue he switched teams
laying down his life for The Avengers in
their fight against the master of evil
over a decade later he was revived and
would eventually become an Avenger
himself in the 80 Simon left the bloated
Avengers roster to pursue a career in
acting as a stunt man he found the
perfect job for a guy who can take any
explosion or weapon head on without
burning or bleeding this Hollywood hook
will become one of the most iconic parts
of Wonder man's character during his
solo comic run and based on casting in
the direction of phase five this is
likely the era of Wonder Man we can
expect to be adapted on Disney plus
totally we should expect this series to
focus on Comedy as its head writer is
Andrew guess a writer out of the 30 Rock
and Community writers rooms for my
fellow human beings he's also the
co-writer for the prophesized and a
movie also note that we're getting coven
of chaos as a spiritual successor to One
Division so I wouldn't be surprised if
Wonder man's Hollywood outings have a
similar parallel with the la-based
She-Hulk series obviously there won't be
any fourth wall breaking but I wouldn't
be surprised if this series plays with
the campiness of the comics for the cast
we have confirmation that Ben Kingsley
will reprise his role as Trevor Slattery
if Slattery does return Stateside from
talo though he's likely gonna have to be
Incognito this guy was broken out of
prison after being part of a terror
first plot that nearly killed the
president and I like you can just walk
into LA Casting and get hired for the
new season of Abbott Elementary Shang
Chi and Avengers King Dynasty director
Destin Daniel [ __ ] is on board as a
producer for the series and will direct
a portion of the episodes so I wouldn't
be surprised if Slattery appears in his
sections before being announced as the
Director of King Dynasty [ __ ] was
rumored to be working on a 10 Rings
focused Disney plus series could
slattery's appearance in Wonder Man hint
at this being the same project as the
rumors or will wonder man possibly be a
tie-in that leads to a dedicated 10 Ring
series down the line either way Slattery
can feasibly be traveling to La under
the protection of the ten Rings after
his involvement in the battle against
the dweller in darkness in my West Coast
Avengers video a few commenters brought
up that Shang Chi operating out of San
Francisco would make him a prime
candidate for that team alongside core
founding member wonder man could
slattery's appearance in this series be
the Smoking Gun that the 10 Rings will
be a bridge that connects Wonder Man to
a greater Avengers plotline more on that
in a second next we have the reports
that Bob Odenkirk is being sought after
for a king role in this series
considering Wonder man's Supporting Cast
from the comics I have a suspicion that
Odin Kirk will play Wonder man's talent
agent Neil sarian this is perfect
casting if true and it's no wonder that
Marvel was like better cow Bob to
pictures Ryan imagine an even smarmyer
Saul Goodman look at these panels and
tell me you can't see Odin Kirk's
Charisma knocking this physicality out
of the park so why is Neil Saroyan such
a big deal for this series well I've got
a theory that he's going to be the big
villain of the Season as well as another
piece of connective tissue between
Wonder Man and the 10 rings from his
very first comic appearance Saroyan is
the embodiment of everything wrong with
Hollywood Orion will do whatever it
takes to get Wonder Man and by extension
himself paid even if it's ethically
dubious or straight up illegal in his
debut he hires one of Wonder Man's
enemies to cause a scene Brian Wonder
Man into a fight in front of the press
even with the massive collateral damage
and nearly deadly encounter droyan can't
help but be proud of his media strategy
on numerous occasions Ryan tries to
bribe Wonder man's screenwriter
girlfriend Alex Flores into writing
biographical screenplays to exploit
Simon's time with the Avengers for a
quick cash in although it was never
thoroughly explored in wonderman's first
run to Ryan was always hinted at having
a darker Edge to him including subtle
implications that he was part of a
criminal Network possibly tied to wonder
man's Rogues Gallery one time he sent
Simon to an audition that turned out to
be a trap by the film editing themed
assassin splice side quest slices
exactly the kind of hokey villain I want
to see on the comedy side of the MCU
this guy is like a reverse Berry he's an
actor turned Hitman why he got fired on
set by a child star forget the vat of
acid try being fired by an Olsen twin I
have no superpowers besides clinical
depression I can't fly I can't teleport
and I can't run real fast if I want to
travel to see my family during the
holidays I have to pay for it and since
I also can't pull plane tickets out of a
pocket Dimension that money's gotta come
from somewhere but here's a little
secret if you're looking to save money
from day to day so you don't have to
skimp on your travel budget you can do
exactly that with upside upside is a
free app that lets you earn cash back on
everyday purchases like gas groceries or
dinner it's easy to use and it works for
me upside is essential for buying gas
well my Tank's not empty I open the
upside app search for a nearby gas
station offering a good deal claim it
and head there to buy gas I can check in
or snap a pic of the receipt and I'm
good to go no special cards to carry or
numbers to remember just upstart's app
on my phone anytime I want I can cash
out to my bank account PayPal or an
e-gift card for Amazon and other brands
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week and has a 4.8
star rating on the app store to get
started download the free upside app and
use code new rockstars to get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of 10 or more reading some of
these early Wonder Man Comics I sort of
wonder if splice was originally intended
to be saroyan's Alter Ego before taking
the character in another direction that
said we do get an actual evil Saroyan
plot during the 2007 Wonder Man limited
series personally I don't think that
this execution of the story lands but
the bones of it could make for some
interesting Source material for an MCU
adaptation long story short Wonder Man
is feeling directionless and conflicted
over his criminal past and his love for
the side flipping Scarlet Witch his
lunch with Neil is interrupted by the
Assassin lady killer as she attempts to
kill a big shot producer in the
restaurant after Wonderman apprehends
her Neil convinces Wonder Man to film a
documentary where he rehabilitates the
Assassin into a hero My Fair Lady Style
with the help of blue Simba sorry I mean
alt girl Tony the Tiger oh wait that's
actually Beast they actually succeed but
in an Abrupt left field twist ceruyan is
revealed to be one of the high-ranking
members of the Assassin organization
that trained Wonder man's Eliza
Doolittle also he has mind control
Powers all of a sudden so Ryan then uses
power over Ladykiller to have her lace
The Avengers fruit punch with super
cyanide she resists and takes herself
off the board before Saroyan can
instruct her to do more damage to
Earth's Mightiest Wonder Man then rushes
to Neil's office only to find him
unceremoniously killed by other members
of his organization obviously this plot
line is a little heavy-handed and
ignores a lot of the car salesman charm
of early Nielsen Ryan but the idea that
Simon's agent has been manipulating him
isn't far off from his first depictions
as I said the bones of this story aren't
bad so here's my theory instead of Odin
Kirk's potential role of Saroyan being a
secret leader of a throwaway assassin
organization he's a member of the 10
Rings possibly even a lieutenant
operating the Hollywood blackmail cell
he could choose to take on Wonder Man as
a client not because his powers make him
a great stunt man but because his powers
make him a great assassin this way MCU
Sirion can mirror comic Zemo from Wonder
man's Origins to Ryan being the greedy
son of a gun that he is might want to
use Wonder Man in a power grab against
wenwoo's daughter and the newly
established 10 Rings leader Jai Ling
obviously snoring won't get far but
Reckless confidence is par for the
course in Hollywood it might even be
interesting to see Wonder Man develop
romantic feelings for xiling if she
makes an appearance seeing as he has a
thing for bad girls it's highly unlikely
that we'll get a Wando Wonder Man
romance in the end see you like we have
in the comics so Jai Ling might be the
perfect love interest for Simon I don't
see Wonder Man flipping xiling to the
light side like he did with Lady Killer
so this relationship would be destined
for heartbreak like so often is the case
for his comic book Persona follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]